yeah well better late than never nah
girl why girls trip
so girls trip with the movie about these
ladies back in the day in their heyday
there were a group of friends had a lot
of fun together then they grew up got
careers found success now they don't
hang out as much and I kind of drops
that on you earlier on in the movie and
I really like that I like the fact that
it started out on the foot of
sentimentality and the sentiment got so
as one of these ladies has business in
New Orleans she's like hey let's bring
my friends get the group back together
let's have a girls trip part of me that
wants to call this basically female
hangover big part of me that doesn't
because it's different this movie does
bring the last whatever movie like this
comes out I'm like do I have to be a
girl in order to actually connects with
this movie and now didn't happy with
bridesmaids didn't have to with this
there are jokes that are definitely
geared towards women in it you don't
have to be a woman to find the humor he
was there and I was laughing my ass off
the standout is the fun spunky friend
dude she was awesome the first couple
jokes are like are your jokes gonna be
forced the entire time I fell she
brought it she was rat I would hang out
with her a long time I always consider
grapefruit to be the most disgusting of
the fruits she doesn't make it so veg
you makes grapefruits cool and I love
the synergy among these ladies as a
whole you know sometimes Jada
pinkett-smith I give her a hard time but
she really is good and rolls like this
cheese belongs you know there's that one
friend who was a lot of fun back in the
day then she had a couple kids this you
became super overly responsible it was
fun to see someone shed the layer of
cobwebs through a situation like that
and the reason I can't really call it
the female hangovers the hangovers dude
it was laughs there's hysterical laugh I
laugh every time I watch the movie it's
a lot of fun it's a lot of Vegas so this
one vote New Orlean it does turn on the
drama when it needs to the end to the
movie have a really good message I will
say the movies a bit fuel are maybe
15-20 minutes too long granted it does
justify its length by having the
dramatic angle didn't change back that I
walked away going a movie could have
been a bit shorter and not all of the
jokes totally landed with me I saw this
movie in a packed auditorium was a lot
of ladies having fun and a couple of
jokes like none of us were lottery not
like I was the [ __ ] to chrome much
and Daniel like I'm not laughing
you gave your lab a couple of jokes in
the movie didn't really stick of landing
and none of us really laughs I didn't
young girls trip surprised the hell out
of me and apprehensive going into it
like how much can i connect with this
movie I actually enjoyed it it was funny
it was heartfelt it had a good message a
couple of good messages in it movie does
run a bit too long but if you're going
to see this movie hopefully it's a
packed auditorium with a lot of ladies
out there doing their
or Lee's girls night there's something
about that audience energy man just make
the movie more fun and yet I will say
girls trip is definitely a good time no
alcohol required OH - who are we kidding
I'm sangria or you know Scotch ain't
probably sangria and just letting you
guys know I will be in Las Vegas through
Saturday that convention going to be
awesome as we've gone there for the Star
Trek convention should be a lot of fun
however this is me letting you know that
I won't have my review for Dark Tower up
for you until the latter part of the
weekend just hold on tight I'll get it
to you I guess a girls trip have you
seen it what did you think about it or
what's the funniest movie you have seen
lately what movie really made you laugh
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]